this is a production of Cornell
University
my name is Tom with lo I'm the Faculty's
mo in the horticulture section sips and
today we're going to be doing some trash
shop as many of you may know the toward
sustainability for me started the first
year beginning of classes this past
spring and it was catalyzed by our own
faculty colleague Jay Mount Pleasant
when she realized how much junk there
was and I say John the trash but how
much reusable or recyclable or
compostable things we produced at all of
our meetings and it was basically just
going into our landfill so Jane convened
a sustainability committee and over the
past nine months or so we've been trying
to encourage everyone to do things like
bring their own utensils to events like
this and bring your own cup super pumped
in and so forth the really big challenge
that's facing the committee and I
the cornell as well right now is
upscaling our composting operation
composting happens what it's very
difficult to make it real inefficient
and we've got multiple sources multiple
kinds of stuff and many of our look of
composting or smaller scale local
composting operations data separately
stuff so our composting or our
sustainability committee decided that
catch everybody getting posted beginning
of the semester and talk about waste
management broadly
and how it works and how we can make it
work better this is going to be a tag
team presentation our first presenter is
going to be Jane Mount Pleasant and I I
don't have any cool pictures for any of
these people but um rest assured i think
that they will all have their their own
entertainment elucidated things to show
us do it so we're going to be treated to
talks by Jane by three graduate students
Anika Coomer is about branstrom and one
on Williams and they're going and
talking about different aspects
so Jay
thank you very much time for that very
nice introduction but I do want to say
that it's mostly the graduate students
that have been doing the lion's share of
this work and I'm really grateful to to
be working with them we are going to
talk about race management f or now one
of the first things is how much wish do
we generate and it is a pretty
mind-boggling term but we're twenty-one
thousand times in 2014 and you can see
the compost is about forty percent of
that the next big thing is our kind of
commonly understood recycle and reuse
and over 20 percentage up in landfill
but when we think look at these big
numbers how much is a ton a lot of us
have a hard time visualizing attack well
this is one at time of landfill waste
looks like at least volume rights and
the weight right so you kind of get an
idea of what you know 21,000 you know
elephants that's an awful lot of stuff
that were thrown
but let's go back and look a little bit
more at our over always a large portion
of it is actually compost and about
almost ninety percent in his plant and
animal woods right animal waste being
animal waste from art for farm
operations and plant waste can come from
all over campus food scraps make up only
about twelve percent of that in terms of
recycling and reusing we have close to
3,000 tons the biggest chunk is what we
commonly call single stream this is the
stuff that we put in it's the recycled
paper and recycled plastic and that's
about fifty percent yard waste also
makes up another big you know component
this ends up in turn into mulch that's
used by
you know pathways and in that garden
beds surprisingly scrap metal is nine
percent electronic scrap five percent
and used furniture about two percent we
have an other category which is over a
hundred tons surprisingly you used oil
whether it's cooking oil or motor and
pump oil right use cooking oil
fifty-four percent is motor oil on two
percent batteries twelve percent entire
stoppers so who's in charge of all this
cornell university's are five operations
and waste management and we are just
delighted this morning to have two
representatives of that group here with
us this is for fun and george wit and if
you ever want to want it to be a groupie
these are folks who want to tell ground
they really do great stuff and we should
all know who they are and and be very on
environment of them this is their
website anything you want to know about
waste at Cornell you can probably find
it on this website so here they are
spring and George and they're always
thinking about how to do a better job of
managing you wasted so where does all by
myself well the landfill waste which is
a huge amount over three thousand times
casella which is a local company it
takes a Seneca metal landfill up in
Waterloo New York and this is a 400-acre
operation that is at the north end node
kind of Durbin and Senator flakes we
also our compost wisdom on site on
campuses Farm Services does this and
it's a it's a commercial sized operation
we also have an institute to send our
waste management institute at Cornell
does research on all aspects of
composting both looking at universal
stuff how to compost dairy cows and
and dead deer that they find out I rode
on they offer all sorts of services to
sit across the country maybe I don't
know this new york state about how to do
a better job of a posting our single
stream recycling County Solid Waste
scrap metal a bunch of different vendors
electronic scrap some king in our fort
before reuse furniture who would have
ever thought 57 tons some of it goes
into a public auction at Cornell we have
a used furniture inventory and a Cornell
assets mass transfer program where if
departments or units colleges have
excess furniture there's ways to find
out if other units their colleges can
use it and so you don't end up thinking
to the to the landfill we also give
stuff to community news programs and
then finally dump and run this is the
program that in the spring when students
are moving out in the spring term they
can collect all of their excess
furniture and clothing and appliances
and just unbelievable things it's stored
sorted and stored over summer and then
in August the first weekend when on
cornell students come back particular
first-year students and then by these
are his items and the reports on putting
them in into the landfill if you
wondering what happens for the cooking
oil that goes to the national oil
recycling in north rose New York they
use motor and pump oil to New York
Pennsylvania mattresses they get reused
at University sleep- right eight tons of
wood pellets go to a company in Syracuse
batteries seven tons to a national out
tires casella distribute such accomplice
to make into athletic turn turn
and very much that's not much more
there were new compost rules that
started August fifteenth and the new
rules on the Cornell campus say food
scraps only the only thing you can put
in our yellow compost bins are food
scraps any might say ah so many other
things will compost right well the
problem of is contamination and our
dining halls and everybody who tries to
compost on the large down as a problem
with people who throw things in there
that shouldn't be composted so for
example what we're now saying as things
like the compostable cops and even
things like a perk up sets a container
and paper plates that you might think
would be compostable and all that
wonderful compostable plastic where it
cannot go into compost why because it
doesn't really compost and this is from
Seneca compost and what you see is just
tons of stuff that's in there compost
that doesn't right now okay so what's
the solution to this well if we keep
doing it Seneca compost with other
companies that do cockles they just
refuse to take it so Cornell dining is
stuck with the compostable materials
what you're doing it right so the
solution is Cornell is no longer
accepting um things like the silverware
Twitter regime of the compost is oniel
demons road doesn't take
they do so white this is kind of
attendance it's the same it doesn't
matter nobody takes it because it
doesn't compos like so if you do food
scraps at home and it goes through to
tompkins county food scraps which goes
to failure good compost they won't take
it all right so we know how Cornell does
it and now the question is well why
should we really care about this and how
do we compare with other countries and
other parts level west and turning it
over to my channel x cubed I
you know wait the waste management of
enormous you just heard about compared
to the rest of the mess and I was like
to start with stable in this table
summarize the proportion raised which is
probably this post and it shows the
denim bars from all of America
never tried to point of two numbers
first
plastics
everyday basis and you can see here
eight point eight percent actually
problem
between the other at my 2% and end on
landfills and the same is here with food
scraps only four point eight percent of
all constructs that ends up in
composting facilities this means when if
I % all mechanics and up either in a
landfill of a burden in the incinerator
and that was very surprised to talk by
these little numbers because it would be
very easy for us just to comfort
properly
so how is this just a reminder relate to
Cornell so seventy-nine percent of all
our way since either in recycling or
composting and in comparison to canal
the United States only thirty-five
percent of our greatest parody and
proper at this post
but why does it matter if organic animal
diamonds but lack of our composting
facility
the issue is when we are you know the
process in a composting facility is
before organics place organic composting
facility
when they get deep composed under
aerobic conditions and co2 instruments
32 part of the next natural short-term
carbon cycle however if you put it on
the landfill the conditions are
anaerobic and this means next to co2
also methane and nitrous oxide are
produced and these are very bad
greenhouse gas gets and how bad they
actually are 50
it shows a global warming potential of
Deputies and under global warming
potential we understand potential of
given mascara in comparison to color
dioxide and methane it McClain is
twenty-five percent words and not 25
times worse and matches oxide a
clearance
and this actually resulted in this chart
these are you are going to have gas
emissions from waste management skills
in the US from 1990 to 2014 and the
y-axis shows and illusions and million
metric tons of carbon dioxide equivalent
and you can see that the majority of it
comes from Nashville that's because
anaerobic it's followed by wastewater
treatment by around fifteen to twenty
percent and it and so much because it's
also happening under anaerobic
conditions I'm glad composing actually
has a tiny fraction of it
so i'm waiting now just look at the
methane production of emissions from
landfills its twenty two percent at 20.2
percent and the third last source of
methane emitted in the US
um yeah now I've given you all the
numbers but when we actually look at the
percentage of the greenhouse gases which
are made
waste screens in comparison to all that
it only makes 2.5% so this number is
playing in part of you think why should
you care it's special tiny percentage
power however any penny counts and
actually at least two point five percent
are very easy to be reduce and everyone
can contribute by recycling
to make it happen so I'm not over
ok
so talking specifically about for now we
know that 75 percent of the waist is not
taken to know myself but keep in mind
this includes manure and
pruning ways
so we
a lot better the grants go and one of
the things that we want you to take with
you today is that recycling is great for
many reasons but it is not going to
solve our problems so granted recycling
can reduce waste sent to life clothes
and sit incinerators sorry for many
products that results in a lot less
energy needed to produce new things in
comparison to using raw or burger
materials it creates jobs beyond logic
Rica and we can also be the recycled
products will be sold to other end users
for cheaper than the raw material and
depending on the material that we're
talking about recycling can save energy
when process interview material into new
things from recycled materials so you
can see here materials like glass not a
huge energy safe but aluminum cans and
copper wire are way more significant if
we're talking about reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions you can see
things like copper wire steel cans and
certain plastics can really help in
reducing the
greenhouse gas emissions associated with
making things forever new classics
however things like office paper which
we do consume a lot of and normally
think i will just recycle it and it's
okay it actually takes produce this
greenhouse gases to recycled paper so
that's something that we need to start
this and that this was the biggest
finding for me which should not have
been surprising but it was really
shocking for me to read that recycling
is actually really expensive and if we
talk about only money it costs the city
a lot of money to recycle feet usually
because it implies transportation
storage sorting a lot of labor and
unfortunately things like cheap oil
prices and relief sons of labor
contributed to it not being very
sustainable to a segment so this comes
from a paper which is actually the only
paper that i found that actually
analyzes recycling as a
from an economic standpoint and what
they found was that if society recycles
ten percent of its waste and in that ten
percent of its waste is majority metal
it's actually a good thing but the more
the higher the proportion of the
recycling that happens the more
expensive it is or the city and the
society in general
to do this the second and keep in mind
that if we are in certain places like
the United States of America all this
recycled product also gets transported
to this is like China to meet process so
there's a huge cost to recycling that we
don't really see and then we need to
start thinking about so you come cartoon
with hilarious
even though we don't see the trash it is
always there and I want to share and eat
a story that I thought about this
morning a couple of years ago in my
hometown tiny little silly city called
go with that Columbia around seven
million quickly prepare there was
political crisis that led to trash my
being picked up and so all the sudden
least spoil people that god damn trash
picked up three times a week we're not
getting the trash pickup guess we'll
find out on the street but nobody's
and within two weeks people started
writing about how they never saw their
trash and seeing their traffic for the
first time and smelling it and seeing
what comes with it was a really huge
lesson to us and maybe we should start
cutting down our trash the big takeaway
from the seminar we want is you guys all
of us to reduce it's the big first art
right and we should start thinking about
it work and reduce usually means buying
less but then we know it's hard
sometimes you can't you just can't
afford to not buy the six-pack of
peppers of Lebanon
and awful non recyclable bag so maybe
you should try to reuse and instead of
coming up with new for a plastic baggies
we should try to reuse the ones we
already have and then finally you can
tell optimize recycling as I have
pointed out only a percent of the
plastic as a better cycling so we can
definitely do that and then of course if
you want to bring reusable place your
picnics we totally support that so
there's a lot of stuff happening on
campus that we may not see just because
it is not in every room with the normal
blue recycling bins but we have plastic
bag and film recycling which you have to
go up to the priceline is loading dock
or to the mailroom supplies but they're
there we also have composting we have
battery recycling and out of trying to
cycling which sometimes you don't see
it's like I said you have to go search
for them so the only two places I know
of or hello Newman in rice hall where
you can actually leave your old mouse
that doesn't work in your battery
chargers with don't care and then
there's also really cool initiatives
going on mostly led by students we
bayern mental collaborative they go by
eko is actually this huge group that
gathers all the organizations on campus
to do environmentally focused activities
and then there's also to the cornell
truth or covering networks but i did not
know about it absolutely brilliant they
go to the dining hall and then repackage
the fruit the food that's already been
prepared and then distribute it to the
food countries through the friendship
donation center
and if you want to go beyond Cornell
there's other stuff we can all do so
like we've already probably told you a
million times bring your own cup cutlery
and
and you start doing it for lunch every
day that'd be great there's also a great
opportunity to teach people so I have
the experience during apple fest where I
told somebody that this tiger cub was
not compostable and he was totally
heartbroken but and toddler we all see
it happening around campus all the time
people just don't pay attention and they
just tossed their bottles or their kin
and the first day as I come across and
it's just a matter of staying to that
person hey maybe you should pay
attention there's a recycling bin next
door I found this recently and I thought
it was really cool you can opt out a
racemic junk mail and catalogs you don't
have to ask from junk mail and catalogs
but apparently you can tell them that
you don't want it if that makes more
sense so if you go to this website they
take care of all the actual contacting
for you you just enter your address and
tell if you don't want and then I
figured I would throw this in you can
all drive less and walk a little bit
more you need in platform so we've also
set up this email account and we're
hoping to become a resource for
everybody I'm wait
related things any questions feel free
to email us and we'll do our best to
respond now there's two more things I
want to say before we wrap this up why
is we are always looking for new members
and volunteers so if you are interested
in getting involved in any way and
incapacity please let us know you can
either Imams talk to us at the end you
can
we're also underneath here
food scraps only even though your heart
shows no stop posting not a porno people
ok this one adds up in the recycling bin
all right where's the other night ok
custodian we have two custodians Jeremy
and and Larry if you have a used light
wall get find the custodian and they
have special places to put them it
doesn't matter if it's fluorescent in
the tonality right now with you all my
balls go to the custodians do not put
them in the length oh right there's a
little thing if you try to put it in in
the in one of the trash thing because
we're such a large
the light bulbs the hackers Eiffel
can be compact fluorescents that work
so that when people have real onions
I've saw people struggling over little
pieces of wood like your serger ecology
and I think spring said just landfill
right it is hard it should be
compostable but we got on the line so
Jan has questioned it since birth
actually enter the waste management
boots so that this is bri really enjoyed
this learned a lot and it's great to do
a better job of what to do with our
waste but they're also initiatives on
campus to reduce the amount of
purchasing that we're doing the amount
of packaging we get with all of our I
mean get it WB Mason sends me put in an
order one day get four boxes each with a
little item in at the next day and it
just seems like there's ways of reducing
not just doing a better job of recycling
but how do we actually reduce the amount
of waste we're getting on pants Springs
probably don't you get hours a day thank
you yeah that's what you do that
stochastic um so there's a few things
going on earth there's there's a few
things
so one is
stay involved campus committee
that is working on no sudden here
mission to demarcate offer me a package
Geneva cable 10 hi Geneva so so there's
a the president sustainable campus
committee has 10 focus teams around
sustainable issues one of those teams
ways but there's also one of those teams
that is procurement and so they are
focusing very hard on that so one of the
things that you've done for W makes
about staples is for example you
couldn't place an order for less than
fifty dollars to try to force
departments to group their orders so
that they only send the one box and I
will admit that why I started getting my
feet into the procurement world I'll be
getting the birth of the time but but
the conversations are happening so like
we rebid the furniture been last year
the first time in like 10 years and it
was great because we know all these
people they're talking about making sure
that our vendors can supply as furniture
flights so George me I will tell you
that our big gripes is all the modular
furniture people think its Legos but
it's all ball hung in panel hung and we
start taking apart you end up losing a
lot of it so trying to ensure that we
have things are easily movable and can
be used in multiple different ways and
not just like the one way um no question
if you go to a recycling seminar that
number one type of conversations
procurement is what you buy is it turn
what here to part getting rid of but a
lot of that is getting people to think
about it so Jade knows my army and
Georgian even program we've been working
on reducing the size of traction
computers and having people
so people think about what they you've
done building audits what we find is
both of that wasted actually bringing
stuff in for lunch so you know you're
outside of laboratory spaces and
you see a lot of food waste is our COO
related ways let me point out a lot of
that material is we've done it we don't
see much food people do eat it but a lot
of packaging so when these guys are on
you about Tupperware I swear tupperware
is the answer can you think I mean one
of the things that we know the least
about is the plastic that that you
called films right technical work so
what and we do have plastic films oh
that you can dispose of import on first
and second floors the question is what
qualifies as a tough film so give us
detective bill yes and don't suspend our
cycle film of plastics is it has to be
soft it can't be quickly yes I was
looking for something that was creepy in
here ah freak lead right here this is
crinkly it does not go it has to be
landfill right so if it crinkles like
cellophane so quickly years literally
this is
wave you've been found with naturally
and how people describe the difference
between recycled annulment not
because the folks over
can't let the Whiteman's pasta
ok
before you look
they told me that
right that's that single stream if it'll
hold for you can put it in a single
stream recycling oh if it's a good mom
if it holds form we go
plastic if it's so soft like this
so Bubba crab can go here
but like that that plastic doesn't like
kids toys
not a single string
the only thing the only plastic that we
frequently get that doesn't go in single
string that is hard is styrofoam the
next landfill yes that is landfill and
Northeast United States we don't have
anyone to send
place the Portland
and somewhere anyone but that's why
we're not shipping it there and it's too
fluffy and it's
the shipping of it does not count around
so you'll hear about more for example
so Walmart does a really good job with
their styrofoam because they're driving
their own trucks and backhaul it
seems to do it but if you're just
shipping for shipping sake
formel recycle
oh no styrofoam and the truth is so
there's there's actually very limited
amount of serve on campus
the computer equipment is
Dell's working very hard and that's for
being
dell is working on hardware packaging
the styrofoam that we see
where I'm sorry to first nobody out the
lake if you're shipping part of the name
oh sorry
but in such cases we don't let it rain
and they don't have a better option
right now we have a question method yes
the court out dining halls we're doing
the disposable trays and utensils I
don't know if they're still doing that
yeah it's because of the drought right
right Tyler's or at least right now yeah
so what are your thoughts on that and
how is that affecting the moment so wait
it's probably not because look so good
this year a wet cornell dining told me
wasn't this it is taking a giant bite
out of their their budget the landfill
waste from
it's not a good thing but I am on the
drought committee amanti with the draft
committees and I was the first one to
say
sometimes you have to make a choice
this is one of those times the drought
is quite serious is it still are they
still doing that yeah you're still doing
it we're hoping with
we're going to get better but I have a
three o'clock on that so but if things
don't improve what it is doing is it is
having a healthy enough to keep
brought water
and right now we're having
that articles there
I think Laurie also wanted to remind
everybody that Hopkins County
recycling waste will help you dispose of
most everything and put it in the
appropriate place and most of it is free
right
unless you f huge amounts or if you have
freezers or things like
that they charge you
that but if you have questions about
home waste hopkins company recycles
birth or the compostable forts instances
about the more expensive
and if we're not most
why do we buy yeah I don't know what the
enemies I can use for campus the costs
are about the same our procurement over
the years to been able to contact a very
good price
a lot of what you're seeing are ones
that
so there's still a lot of material out
there it's amazing
we'll go back to plastic
one thing you'll notice
really hard to tell the difference
just a party problem
what I started last December
most consumer customers are sorting
stuff activity
is almost fifty percent
so the hope is that by having
well actually hopefully
more condos
it's also
easier for departments
trying to change the rules
it was just getting
alright
so against the ideal
to mainly
making all of that stuff that is like
claims biodegradable and is that a
legally issue due to policymaking or it
doesn't actually like why are you can
big label it as x so why they can label
despite agreeable to it breaks down over
X many years
I don't think the hexamon your village
okay so most of all is a little
different because
big challenge as far as white goes blue
scraps
those with social plastics don't break
down very quickly and the other piece is
so if you go out to Cornell compost
facility they've always kept the dining
compost
is that on their own fields because of
old forks and knives and Pepsi
today college
so
so there's that but the other thing
isn't
you guys let me know if this isn't right
because this is therefore never cease
interpretation on
which is that the controls for plastics
podcast format
and regular classes
what happens is also with
all sorts of people with lots of fellows
you're only capturing
soon as they walk out the ball
cycling
and then we're also that materials that
you into an film
good
doesn't help the recycling industry all
we're just
exactly lida my person silk recycling
it's all finally accomplished you can
contaminated and contaminate at East End
at the landfill is that the stain with
recycling yeah so if you recycling gets
he and sorted down at atkins county
which is why for anyone you're working
labs very often labs for clinical spaces
so we've had work really part of labs
where people want to do the right thing
and say on this yields that a little
recycle and it's like a that's no flaw
but the
our hand sorting this material so we
don't want people thinking
whatever goes on
so so so compost however there's no
sporting process for us on campus it
can't am sorted autonomous county
anything that and they capture the
high-value materials the high-value
class
and they sell it that part of how the
county funds the recycling program what
they don't get mixed in with our
residential
Oh to ontario sorry we don't use
something competitive
there was one of my questions when you
have a great pianist nakamoto's there
ah
and then they get started again where
there's people but then there's also
back into place
as well
nationally
so look out for cycling gets hand sorta
general it's always your head okay or
the other we are actually really really
lucky that we have
county
if you go to tioga county which
what about miles south
they don't do programs are different so
you have a great amount of
not just state by state county by
actually sorry
almost every day
nice
the chemicals owner
forgiving her then
she's wonderful that she pays her
employees
they can sort everything to make sure
that what she sends out
is
she's
a black
vantages
why do we do a better job
we do if you compare so we have some
there's some other colleges out there
that what
straight up throughout the proctors dis
phenom you know and they're better for
different reasons
it's very much very much fun our
community in our members so so first off
tompkins county is it is
their director is barb extra no
prisoners who yep should point out
graduate and it has been profession in
life she can work on this is an eighties
and has programs work as a resident I
pay for traffic I Recycling's free and
they also have laws in place too
companies to do that right we're really
lucky that way
but we also have a lot of
institution
ha
that is fantastic
part of this place because we have
by in and support team effort public
comments
we're going to comment yes this how to
do it the supply seen walking in I went
to fig yesterday with it open the black
diamond trowel and dr. Thomas time 75
years without 51 miles so it goes a lot
of fun to say about their child just so
you know Cornell leave got a third of
staff drive against others otherwise in
about ninety percent of students
and that I think we made
so thank you very much two presenters
and to visiting guests this was really
fascinating i encourage you to recycle
and repurpose these discussions outside
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu